THIS ECONOMY IS BACK.
>> I AM GREG GUTFELD WITH JUAN
WILLIAMS AND JESSE WATTERS.
IT'S "THE FIVE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> WE ARE EXACTLY ONE YEAR AWAY
FROM THE ELECTION.
IN A MOMENT, WE WILL FILL A TIME
CAPSULE RIGHT HERE WITH ITEMS
THAT BEST SYMBOLIZE THIS COMING
YEAR.
A STRAND OF BERNIE SANDERS'S EAR
HAIR OR A LIFE ALERT FOR VERY
SLOW SLEEPY JOE.
>> SLEEPY JOE.
HE MAKES A MISTAKE EVERY TIME HE
SPEAKS.
I CAN SEE THESE HANDLERS.
LIKE WITH HORSES THE HANDLERS.
ALL RIGHT, GET HIM OFF.
HE'S BEEN UP THERE LONG ENOUGH.
THEY ARE SCREAMING, GET OFF.
SLEEPY JOE GET OFF THE STAGE,
PLEASE, JOE!
>> THAT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP LAST
NIGHT AT A WILD RALLY IN
KENTUCKY TALKING ABOUT THE STUFF
THAT MATTERS LIKE THE GREAT LOU
DOBBS.
>> THE GREAT LOU DOBBS.
HE SAID WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
TOOK OVER, HE USED TO AT A TRUMP
IS A GREAT PRESIDENT.
THEN HE SAID TRUMP IS THE
GREATEST PRESIDENT SINCE RONALD
REAGAN.
>> THIS YEAR WILL BE HISTORICAL
AND HYSTERICAL.
A TWO WAY BATTLE.
NOT JUST A ONE WAY STREET.
ASK CORRUPT POLITICIAN NANCY
PELOSI AND ADAM SCHIFF.
>> CORRUPT POLITICIANS NANCY
THEY ARE CORRUPT.
NANCY PELOSI STOP WASTING TIME
AND GO BACK TO HER DISTRICT IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND HELP THE
HOMELESS.
GET RID OF THE DRUGS.
GET RID OF THE NEEDLES THAT ARE
LYING ALL OVER THE STREET.
>> CAN WE ALREADY PREDICT WHO
MIGHT WIN?
THE IMPEACHMENT GAMBIT SUGGESTS
DEMS KNOW IF THEY STICK TO THE
ELECTION THEY WILL LOOSE.
IMPEACHMENT IS THE FIRE ALARM
THEY PULL TO CANCEL SCHOOL ON
THE DAY OF THE BIG TEST.
EITHER THAT OR MOVE TO CANADA.
THE NEW BATTLEGROUND STATE POLLS
LOOK GOOD TO TRUMP.
THE MEDIA CLINGS TO HIS LOW
FAVORABILITY POLLS.
THEY BELIEVE AMERICA ADORES WHO
THEY VOTE FOR.
THEY DON'T NEED A MR. NICE GUY,
RIGHT?
>> THE GUY IS A BAD [BLEEP].
IN HIS OWN WAY.
>> HMMM.
TRUMP IS AN MMA-POLITICIAN.
IF A CAGE DEBATE HE WILL FISH
HOOK HIS OPPONENTS.
TO SHOW YOU HOW GOOD THE COUNTRY
IS DOING UNDER TRUMP IS TO WHAT
IS THE NEWS BECAME NOW.
TRUMP'S MISSPELLINGS.
WHETHER HE WAS BOO'D OR MORE
SWEATY COVERAGE OF A PHONE CALL.
ALL OPINION PROBLEMS ABOUT
PERSONALITY.
IT WASN'T ALWAYS LIKE THIS.
IN THE PAST WE HAD BODY BAGS AND
DEPATCHED PROFESSIONALISM.
NOW WE HAVE NO BODY BAGS AND A
WILD MAN.
I PERFECT THAT TRADEOFF.
IN A YEAR SO WILL A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
PREFER --
HE IS SHAKING HIS HEAD.
>> HE GOT UP SET WHEN THEY SAID
THE GREAT LOU DOBBS.
>> YOU KNOW WHEN IT'S HYSTERIA.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW PAW GET.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS IS THE TIME CAPSULE.
WE REMOVE THE TOP.
LET'S GO AROUND.
IT LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING ELSE I
BOUGHT IN COLLEGE.
JUDGE, WHAT WOULD YOU PUT IN THE
TIME CAPSULE WHICH WE WILL OPEN
NEXT YEAR WHEN THE ELECTION IS
DONE.
WHAT IS IT?
>> OH!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> PASS IT DOWN.
>> THAT LOOKS LIKE THE CONTAINER
IN THE PANTRY.
AND EVERY SUNDAY YOU OPEN IT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> OKAY, THIS IS MY GAVEL.
IT'S NOT A GLASS GAVEL BECAUSE
IT DIDN'T BREAK.
IT'S LEUCITE.
IT WILL BE TIME FOR JUSTICE.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT WHEN
THE NEXT ELECTION COMES AROUND,
IT WILL BE TIME TO NOT WORRY
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT INDICTMENTS
ARE POLITICAL OR NOT POLITICAL.
IT'S ABOUT TRUE JUSTICE IS.
THAT'S WHY I PUT MY GAVEL IN
THERE.
I COUNT ON JUSTICE.
>> NICE.
JUAN?
>> I AM NOT SURE WHAT THAT
MEANT.
>> IT MEANS INDICTMENTS.
>> OF TRUMP?
>> NO, OF ALL OF THE DEEP
STATERS.
>> DON'T LOCK HIM UP YET.
>> I HAVE THIS, JUDGE.
I HAVE THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I AM HOPING IN A YEAR WE STILL
HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL FORM OF
GOVERNMENT THAT WE DON'T HAVE AN
AUTOCRACY.
WHOEVER WINS CAN TAKE OFFICE.
>> COME ON.
>> YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS WILL
SAY CONGRATS DONALD WHEN HE WINS
AGAIN?
>> THE DEMOCRATS ACKNOWLEDGED
HIS VICTORY LAST TIME.
>> WHEN WAS THAT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> YOU CREATED THE RESISTANCE.
>> HILLARY CLINTON CONCEDED THE
ELECTION.
>> NOT THAT NIGHT!
>> REMEMBER IT'S DONALD TRUMP
WHO SAID I AM NOT SURE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JUDGE, PUT IT IN THIS WAY OR
NONE OF THE THINGS ARE GOING TO
FIT.
THAT'S BETTER.
NOW EVERYTHING IS FIT.
>> OKAY.
>> I WAS TOLD TO DO THAT.
I DIDN'T THINK OF THAT MYSELF.
I WILL PUT IN THE CAPSULE THE
POLLS THAT SHOW DONALD TRUMP
LOSING TO WARNEN, BERNIE SANDERS
AND JOE BIDEN BY 15 POINTS.
THE SAME POLE A YEAR OUT BEFORE
LAST ELECTION HAD HILLARY
CLINTON BEATING DONALD TRUMP BY
12 POINTS.
WHEN I OPEN THE CAPSULE, I DON'T
THINK DONALD TRUMP WILL HAVE
LOST TO ANY OF THESE PEOPLE BY
15 POINTS.
I WILL STUFF THIS IN LIKE THAT.
JUAN LIKES TO CITE POLL.
THIS WILL BE A MESSAGE IN A
BOTTLE.
THE MESSAGE WILL BE THAT YOU
WERE WRONG.
>> ALL RIGHT.
DANA?
>> I COULD HAVE A COUPLE OF
THINGS?
>> YES.
I AM NOT BRINGING THE RULES.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF POLITICAL
ADS SO I GOT EARPLUGS.
>> VERY GOOD.
>> I HAVE ALSO THE BEST
PREDICTOR OF THE POLLS.
TODAY'S STOCK MARKET.
HIGH?
>> YES.
>> DOW JONES AND NASDAQ AND S&P
500 RECORDS.
AND THE ONE I AM REALLY PROUD OF
IT.
YOUNG PEOPLE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW.
SMELLING SALTS FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO FAINT WITH THE RESULTS.
>> THAT'S SO TRUE.
>> WHERE DID YOU FIND THESE?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THE THING IS, THEY DON'T SELL
SMELLING SALTS ANYMORE.
THESE ARE BATH SALTS.
>> THESE ARE ILLEGAL.
YOU GOT THESE ON STREETS.
>> NO, THURSDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL.
>> WHY DON'T THEY SELL THEM
ANYMORE?
>> THEY HAVE DRUGS IN THEM.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
YOU GET THE POINT.
>> THIS IS GREAT.
I AM ADDING A MOUTH GUARD
BECAUSE IT MIGHT BE THE ONLY
THING LEFT AFTER 2020.
IT'S GOING TO BE A FIGHT.
>> NOT SO BAD.
>> YOU CONTAMINATED THE CAPSULE.
>> YOU NEVER WORE A MOUTHPIECE
BEFORE?
>> WHEN I PLAYED POP WARNER
FOOTBALL.
>> GET IT AND CLEAN IT.
WE WILL NEED A NEW ONE.
THIS WILL BE USED FOR A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> WHERE WILL WE PUT THE TIME
CAPSULE?
>> IN A PLACE WHERE NO ONE EVER
GOES TO.
THE FOX NEWS GYM.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I KID.
BUT IT WILL BE PLAYED IN A
LOCKER AT THE FOX NEWS GYM WITH
ITS OWN PERSONAL TRAINER.
WE WILL OPEN IT -- DO WE OPEN
IT?
THE NIGHT OR WAIT UNTIL
WEDNESDAY?
>> I THINK WEDNESDAY.
>> YEAH, WEDNESDAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT WE WILL DO.
>> WE ALL HAVE TO BE ON.
THAT WILL BE FUNNY IF SOME
SUFFICIENT -- SOME OF US ARE NOT
HERE ANYMORE.
DANA.
>> DID YOU PUT THE MOUTH GUARD
IN?
>> NO, YOU WANT A NEW ONE
BECAUSE I PUT IT IN MY MOUTH.
>> PUT IT IN.
>> THAT WAS FUN.
>> I NEED MY GAVEL.
>> YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE
GAVEL!
>> YOU WILL GET IT IN A YEAR.
>> WE WILL GET YOU ANOTHER
GAVEL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> IT'S LEUCITE.
YOU CAN'T GET THAT ANYWHERE.
>> WE WILL GET YOU A WOODEN ONE.